I what I have found and what other people I know have found who have spent a lot of time with Rust after having spent a lot of time with another functional language like Elm or like not necessarily Haskell but Elm or Scala or something like that is that if you try programming Rust in a functional style like a really functional style you're going to have a bad time like it's just better to embrace the imperative and just use it like an imperative language. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 157, recorded on November 13th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue our interview with Richard Feldman. And in today's episode, chat about the Rock programming language. What qualifies a language as a functional programming language?
我所发现的以及我认识的其他人所发现的，在花了很多时间使用另一种函数式语言（比如 Elm，或者不一定是 Haskell 但比如 Elm 或 Scala 之类的）之后，又花了很多时间使用 Rust 的经验是，如果你试图以函数式风格（真正意义上的函数式风格）来编写 Rust，你会过得很痛苦，因为最好还是接受命令式，把它当作一种命令式语言来使用。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 157 期，录制于 2023 年 11 月 13 日。我是 Connor，今天我的联合主持人是 Bryce，我们将继续对 Richard Feldman 的访谈。在今天的节目中，我们聊聊 Roc 编程语言。什么让一门语言成为函数式编程语言？
Whether Rust makes the cut and more. Anyways, episode 157. We are back. I mean, we never left, but the listener had to wait a week. So sad. And we're back with Richard Feldman. And now is the part, I think, that we are going to transition to talk all about the ROC programming language.
Rust 是否符合标准等等。无论如何，这是第 157 期节目。我们回来了。我的意思是，我们从未离开，但听众不得不等了一个星期。太让人难过了。我们迎来了 Richard Feldman。现在我想我们要过渡到全面讨论 Roc 编程语言了。
That's R-O-C. And I will just throw it over to you, Richard. Maybe you can start by telling us what is the motivation for this language and sort of what paradigm you're aiming for it to fit into. Because as you know, there are many different paradigms, many different languages, many different use cases. And, you know, there's lots of programming languages coming out these days. But what's the goal that Rock is trying to achieve?
也就是 R-O-C。我就把话交给你了，Richard。也许你可以先给我们讲讲这门语言的动机是什么，以及你希望它契合哪种范式。因为如你所知，有很多不同的范式、很多不同的语言、很多不同的用例。而且，你知道，现在涌现出很多编程语言。但 Roc 试图实现的目标是什么？
Sure. So I guess, I mean, there's the story of like how Rock came to be. But I guess the way that I would sort of pitch it to someone, you know, listening who maybe is familiar with C++ or, you know, is interested in other languages, is that it's a fast, friendly, functional language. That's sort of our tagline. So fast in terms of performance, like runtime performance, not as fast as C++, but fast among sort of automatic memory managed language. And also fast in terms of compile times. Both of those are very important to us. Friendly in terms of user friendliness. So
当然可以。所以我想，关于 Roc 是如何诞生的，有一个故事。但我向可能熟悉 C++ 或对其他语言感兴趣的听众推介它时，我会说它是一门快速、友好、函数式的语言。这算是我们的标语。就性能而言的“快”，比如运行时性能，不像 C++ 那么快，但在自动内存管理的语言中算是快的。在编译速度方面也很快。这两点对我们都非常重要。就用户友好性而言的“友好”。所以
that's both in terms of we try to make the compiler have really nice, friendly, helpful error messages. And also that we try to ship with a lot of tools built into the binary. So you've got testing built in, code formatting, package management, all that the binary. So you've got testing built in, code formatting, package management, all that good stuff. So you don't need separate tools for all those different things. And then functional because it is a single paradigm functional language.
这既包括我们努力让编译器拥有非常友好、乐于助人的错误信息。也包括我们努力在二进制文件中内置大量工具。因此，测试、代码格式化、包管理器等所有这些好东西都内置在二进制文件中。所以你不需要为所有这些不同的事情使用单独的工具。然后是“函数式”，因为它是一门单范式函数式语言。
How's that? So my first question is a fast, friendly, functional programming language. The first thing that my brain thought of was, ooh, does he think that Haskell is a slow, friendly functional programming language. The first thing that my brain thought of was, ooh, does he think that Haskell is a slow, unfriendly functional language? Like, so how does Haskell and Scala and maybe Elixir, those are probably like the three most popular, you know, I'm probably going to get flamed a little bit,
觉得怎么样？所以我的第一个问题是：一门快速、友好的函数式编程语言。我脑海中浮现的第一件事是，噢，他是觉得 Haskell 是一门缓慢、友好的函数式编程语言吗？我脑海中浮现的第一件事是，噢，他是觉得 Haskell 是一门缓慢且不友好的函数式语言吗？那么，Haskell、Scala 以及也许 Elixir——这大概是三个最受欢迎的，你知道的，我可能会挨点骂，
but like, you know, depending on the ranking lists, those are typically in the top five. You know, maybe F-sharp is up there as well, depending what community you're in. How do those, are those considered relatively compared to rock on the slower end or more unfriendly end, or how would you like juxtapose those languages versus rock? Sure. So I would say, I don't think it's unfair to say that rock puts a lot more emphasis on user friendliness than Haskell does. Without making a value judgment on, you know, like people's preferences, just if you look at like
但你知道，根据排名榜，它们通常在前五名中。你知道，也许 F# 也在其中，这取决于你身处哪个社区。与 Roc 相比，这些语言被认为是较慢的一端还是较不友好的一端？或者你会如何将这些语言与 Roc 进行对比？当然。所以我想说，说 Roc 比 Haskell 更重视用户 friendliness，这并不算不公允。在不对人们的偏好做出价值判断的前提下，如果你看一下
an error message that comes out of Rock's compiler versus GHC, it's just, I think it's a lot friendlier, generally speaking, in terms of Rock. Now I should say GHC is much more mature. So one possibility is that the error message you'll get out of Rock's compiler is there was a compiler crash because we are not even at version 0.1 yet, which I don't think you should expect from GHC nearly as much. But assuming you do actually get a normal error that says syntax error or type checking, type mismatch or something like that, we very much take very direct inspiration from Elm on how we structure our error messages. And I think Elms are just the most friendly that I've ever encountered. And that includes Rust. The entire Rock compiler is written in Rust. So I have a lot of extensive experience with both Rust and Elm, and I still find Elm's error messages to be significantly friendlier than Rust's. But so comparing Rock to Scala, I would say that rock should run faster than
Roc 编译器生成的错误信息与 GHC 生成的错误信息相比，我认为总的来说，就 Roc 而言，它要友好得多。现在我应该说 GHC 要成熟得多。所以有一种可能性是，你从 Roc 编译器中得到的错误信息是“编译器崩溃了”，因为我们甚至连 0.1 版本都还没到，我想你对 GHC 就不会抱有那么多的这种预期。但假设你确实得到了一个正常的错误信息，说语法错误、类型检查、类型不匹配之类的，我们在如何构建错误信息方面直接受到了 Elm 的启发。而且我认为 Elm 的错误信息是我遇到过的最友好的。这包括 Rust 在内。整个 Roc 编译器都是用 Rust 编写的。所以我对 Rust 和 Elm 都有丰富的经验，我仍然发现 Elm 的错误信息明显比 Rust 更友好。不过，如果将 Roc 与 Scala 进行对比，我会说 Roc 的运行速度应该比
the Scala. Um, we don't have like direct benchmarks to back that up in significant part because those are kind of hard to do on a whole language level. Um, but also because we don't really have any substantially large rock code bases yet. So, uh, and also we haven't realized all of our sort of ambitions with regards to performance optimization. We've done a lot, but not as much as we plan to do. And then comparing to Elixir, I would say the main thing is that it doesn't really have to do with being fast or friendly or functional. Well, I guess you could make the claim that
Scala 更快。嗯，我们没有直接的基准测试来支持这一点，很大程度上是因为这些在整门语言层面上很难做到。嗯，也是因为我们目前还没有任何相当大的 Roc 代码库。所以，而且我们也没有完全实现我们在性能优化方面的所有雄心壮志。我们做了很多，但没有达到我们计划做的那么多。然后与 Elixir 相比，我想说主要的一点是，这与快、友好或函数式并没有真正关系。好吧，你也许可以声称
Rock is more strict about being functional than Elix guess you could make the claim that Rock is more strict about being functional than Elixir is, in the sense that Rock is purely functional, so there is no mutation, there's no side effects, whereas Elixir certainly allows side effects. But also, Elixir is, for the moment, dynamically typed, and Rock is statically typed. Depending on who you ask, you could say that is more or less user-friendly. But for me as a user, I definitely like having a language like Rock that has a really simple static type system, so certainly much simpler than Scalas or Haskells, and also one that has full type inference, so I don't need to annotate anything if I don't want to. All those things are true, and so, you know, I guess depending on your
Roc 比 Elixir 更严格地坚持函数式，从 Roc 是纯函数式的意义上来说，没有突变（mutation），没有副作用，而 Elixir 肯定允许副作用。但同时，Elixir 目前是动态类型的，而 Roc 是静态类型的。取决于你问谁，你可能会说这或多或少更具用户友好性。但对于我作为一个用户来说，我绝对喜欢有一门像 Roc 这样拥有非常简单的静态类型系统的语言，当然比 Scala 或 Haskell 的要简单得多，而且还具有完整的类型推断，所以如果我不想的话，我不需要注解任何东西。所有这些都是真的，所以，你知道，大概取决于你的
preferences, you might say one of the, you might say, despite the fact that it's got full type inference, I would still prefer a dynamically typed language. And if so, then you would probably prefer Elixir. But for me personally, I like having not only the, having the types available, but also having a language that's designed around the types. I think there's a really big difference. And I've talked with Jose Valim on my podcast, Software Unscripted, several times about types and Elixir and stuff like that. So check out those episodes if you want to hear more about that specific conversation. But I do think there's a significant difference between having a dynamic
偏好，你可能会说其中一个，你可能会说，尽管它具有完整的类型推断，但我还是更喜欢动态类型语言。如果真是这样，那你可能更喜欢 Elixir。但就我个人而言，我不仅喜欢有类型可用，还喜欢有一门围绕类型设计的语言。我认为这有很大的不同。我在我的播客 Software Unscripted 上和 Jose Valim 谈过好几次关于类型和 Elixir 的事情。所以如果你想听更多关于那个特定对话的内容，去听听那些节目吧。但我确实认为，拥有一门动态语言并在事后添加类型，与从第一天起生态系统中的一切都始终围绕类型设计的语言之间，有着显著的区别。
language where you add types after the fact compared to a language where everything in the entire ecosystem is always designed with types from day one. Interesting. Yeah, I definitely love, I mean, I think Haskell was pretty eye-opening the first time, because I think a lot of people conflate explicit types and like strong and static typing. Like they think, oh, if I have this really strong static type system, you know, I'm going to have to explicitly write all my types everywhere. And then you see Haskell and it'll infer the whole type signature of your function, you don't have to do anything. And it's like, well, you can have the best of both worlds, you can have a very, very strong static type system. And you can have all your types inferred. And where you want, you can
有趣。是的，我绝对喜欢——我的意思是，我认为 Haskell 第一次出现时让人大开眼界，因为我认为很多人把显式类型与强静态类型混为一谈。他们认为，噢，如果我有这个非常强的静态系统，你知道，我必须在所有地方显式地写出我所有的类型。然后你看到 Haskell，它会推断出你函数的整个类型签名，你什么都不用做。这就好比，你可以鱼与熊掌兼得，你可以拥有一个非常非常强的静态类型系统，并且可以推断出你所有的类型。而在你需要的地方，你可以
sprinkle them in to make sure you're doing things, you know, the way it is, but it's almost like a failsafe that if you if you don't want to write them, you can get away without writing them, which is pretty phenomenal. So I guess my next question, too, is, you know, a lot of folks I have heard, and you said that you've got a lot of experience as Rust, they end up going from, you know, there's some joke, or I'm not sure if you've seen, we'll link it in the show notes. I hope most of the listeners have seen it. There's a Rust developer interview, YouTube video by this guy. I can't remember if he's wearing like a blue wig but it's a seven minute interview about it's like it's a it's a sketch where he's you know being interviewed about why he loves rust and it is absolutely hilarious and one of the questions
点缀它们以确保你做的事情符合预期，但它几乎就像一个故障保护，如果你不想写它们，你可以不写也能跑通，这相当惊人。所以我想我的下一个问题也是，你知道，我听说很多人——你也说过你有很多 Rust 经验——他们最终从，你知道，有个笑话，或者我不确定你有没有看，我们会在节目笔记中链接它。我希望大多数听众都看过。这是一个 Rust 开发者访谈的 YouTube 视频，由这家伙制作。我记不清他是不是戴着蓝色的假发，但这是一个七分钟的访谈，这是一个小品，讲的是他接受采访时讲述为什么他热爱 Rust，这绝对滑稽透顶。其中一个问题
they ask because everything's like a joke it's like well for someone who's uh doesn't not familiar with haskell how do you recommend them learning rust? And then his answer is deadpan, like, well, what are you talking about? Go learn Haskell first. Like, the first step to learning Rust is going and learning Haskell and then coming and learning Rust, and then you'll love Rust. And so it's this just general idea that Rust is a language that satisfies a lot of functional programmers, and it's quite fast. So is the main difference, it sounds like, is that Rock is aimed at being a friendlier version of Rust? Because Rust does have pretty good error messages
由于一切都是个玩笑，他们问：好吧，对于一个不熟悉 Haskell 的人，你推荐他们如何学习 Rust？然后他的回答面无表情，就像是：你在说什么？先去学 Haskell 吧。学习 Rust 的第一步就是去学 Haskell，然后过来学 Rust，接着你就会爱上 Rust。所以这只是一种普遍的看法，即 Rust 是一门满足了很多函数式程序员的语言，而且它相当快。那么主要的区别，听起来是 Roc 旨在成为 Rust 的更友好版本吗？因为 Rust 确实有相当不错的错误信息
most of the times, depending on exactly what you're doing. Or so like, what would you say, you know, for someone that's evaluating languages for some, you know, speedy, they want a functional language, why would someone choose Rock over Rust? Well, I think if you want a speedy functional languages uh a speedy functional language a good reason to choose rock over rust is that it is a functional language um i i know i've heard people say that rust is a functional language i it doesn't make any sense to me uh rust is like
大多数时候，取决于你具体在做什么。或者说，你会怎么说，对于一个正在评估语言以寻找某种速度快、想要一门函数式语言的人来说，为什么有人会选择 Roc 而不是 Rust？嗯，我认为如果你想要一门速度快的函数式语言——一门速度快的函数式语言，选择 Roc 而不是 Rust 的一个好理由是它是一门函数式语言。嗯，我知道我听过有人说 Rust 是一门函数式语言，这对我来说毫无意义。Rust 就像是
one of the most imperative languages i've ever used and like okay they have like map and filter and stuff like that like these things that also occur in functional languages like they have first class closures and so you can uh do some amount of higher order stuff but like i coming from a functional programming background the first thing that i tried to do in rust when i was um making the compiler for rock was uh i say I say it like it's in the past tense, but actually this is still the parser that we use today. I did everything with parser combinators because that's what I was used to. And I kind of assumed that A, Rust would just sort of magically take care of the performance for me. In fairness, the parser seems to be plenty fast in this style.
我用过的最命令式的语言之一。好吧，他们有 map 和 filter 之类的东西，这些东西在函数式语言中也会出现，他们有一等闭包（first-class closures），所以你可以做一定的高阶操作。但是，作为一个有函数式编程背景的人，当我为了制作 Roc 的编译器而在 Rust 中尝试做的第一件事时——
I have some plans to like rewrite it using SIMD and some other things to make it a lot faster, but nevertheless, it's certainly not the bottleneck in our compilation pipeline, which is already fast by a lot of languages standards, including Rust. But what I have found and what other people I know have found who have spent a lot of time with Rust after having spent a lot of time with another functional language like Elm or like not necessarily Haskell but Elm or Scala or something like that is that if you try programming Rust in a functional style like a really functional style you're going to have a bad time like it's just better to embrace the imperative and just use it like an imperative language I mean we could get into sort of more details on that if you want. But like, to me, if you want to try to do the whole, like, I'm not going to mutate
我说的好像是过去式，但实际上这仍然是我们今天使用的解析器——我用解析器组合子（parser combinators）做了所有事情，因为那是我的习惯。我当时有点假设，A，Rust 会某种程度上神奇地替我处理好性能问题。平心而论，这种风格的解析器似乎足够快。我有计划用 SIMD 和其他一些东西重写它，让它快得多，但尽管如此，它绝对不是我们编译管道中的瓶颈。按许多语言的标准（包括 Rust 在内）来看，我们的编译管道已经相当快了。但我所发现的以及我认识的其他人所发现的，在花了很多时间使用另一种函数式语言（比如 Elm，或者不一定是 Haskell 但比如 Elm 或 Scala 之类的）之后，又花了很多时间使用 Rust 的经验是，如果你试图以函数式风格（真正意义上的函数式风格）来编写 Rust，你会过得很痛苦，因为最好还是接受命令式，把它当作一种命令式语言来使用。我的意思是，如果你想的话，我们可以深入探讨其中的更多细节。但是，对我来说，如果你想尝试做那种“我不会突变任何东西，我不会搞副作用”的事情，如果你有一门围绕这一点设计的语言（比如 Roc、Elm 或 Haskell），它会运行得非常好。但如果你试图在 Rust 中这样做，我认为这简直就是逆流而上。
anything, I'm not going to do side effects thing. It works really nicely if you have a language that's designed around that, like Rock or Elm or Haskell. But if you try to do that in Rust, I think it's just, you're really swimming upstream. Interesting. And it was in using parser combinators to implement your parser that that was the first time that you hit this wall. Well, I literally encountered a Rust error that I have not seen before or since, which was the compiler basically said recursion limit reached. Like you have done too much recursion in your Rust program. I give up. Just stop. Do less of that.
有趣。正是使用解析器组合子来实现你的解析器，才让你第一次遇到了这堵墙。嗯，我确实遇到了一个我以前从未见过、以后也没见过的 Rust 错误，那就是编译器基本上说“达到递归限制”。就像你在 Rust 程序中做了太多的递归。我放弃了。停下来。少做点那个。
I cannot compile your program because you're doing too many. And like in parser combinators, once you get past a certain size, that sort of happens normally. Fortunately, thankfully, I discovered that if I converted some of my higher order functions to macros that were exactly the same thing,
我无法编译你的程序，因为你做了太多递归。就像在解析器组合子中，一旦超过一定规模，这种情况通常就会发生。幸运的是，谢天谢地，我发现如果我把一些高阶函数转换为宏，它们做的是完全相同的事情，
but that sort of took them out of the type system. This was not just about inlining, by the way. I tried making them inline, no dice. The problem was that the Rust type checker could not handle the amount of like recursive structures that I was using there. And so just turning the functions and like doing nothing else,
但某种程度上把它们移出了类型系统。顺便说一句，这不仅仅是关于内联（inlining）。我试过让它们内联，没用。问题在于 Rust 类型检查器无法处理我在那里使用的那种大量的递归结构。因此，仅仅是将函数换掉，不做别的，
but swapping out the top line. So it was a macro instead of a function, keeping the entire implementation the same. That fixed that problem. Then I was able to continue finishing the parser. But like there was a commit where I was just like, oh, like now what I and I kind of thought I was like, have I just dug myself a deep hole and now I have to go back and rewrite the entire like the parser is pretty big at that point. I thought I was going to have to rewrite the whole thing until I found the macro trick. So now if you look at the parser
只是把顶行换成宏，而保持整个实现完全相同。这就解决了那个问题。然后我就能够继续完成解析器了。但当时有一个提交（commit），我当时就想：“噢，现在我……”我当时有点觉得，“我是不是给自己挖了个深坑，现在我不得不回去重写整个……”当时解析器已经相当大了。我以为我不得不重写整个东西，直到我发现了宏的诀窍。所以现在如果你看 Roc 的解析器
code base for rock, you see because it is still in this parser combinator, half macro parser combinator style, you see a bunch of things that are functions that a bunch of things that are macros. And the reason for that mix is just that, like I said, Rust is just not set up for this style of programming. Yeah, it's interesting, actually, that you say that because one of I've not have anywhere near as close the amount of Rust experience as you do, but I've written at this point, I don't know, at least several thousand lines of code. And I was trying to write an equivalent of a C++ mini library that I wrote that basically just provides a bunch
代码库，你会发现因为它仍然处于这种解析器组合子、半宏解析器组合子的风格中，你会看到一堆函数和一堆宏。这种混合的原因就像我说的，Rust 根本不适合这种编程风格。是的，实际上很有趣，你这么说是因为我——我没有你那么多、哪怕接近你那么多的 Rust 经验，但我写过，我不知道，至少几千行代码。我当时试图写一个等价的 C++ 小型库，我写过那个库，它基本上只提供了一堆
of combinatory logic combinators. So if you're familiar with like flip from Haskell, which is the C combinator, just things that are basically function manipulators. And I ran into this issue because I don't fully understand lambdas and closures and rust because in C++, like it's actually pretty straightforward. You know, you need, if you get into the details of it, you know, depending on how you capture your capture variables, it'll, you know, eliminate the trivial copyableness of your lambda. But in general, you've got, you know, eliminate the trivial copyableness of your Lambda.
组合逻辑组合子（combinatory logic combinators）。所以如果你熟悉 Haskell 中的 flip，也就是 C 组合子，那些基本上就是函数操作符的东西。我遇到了这个问题，因为我没有完全理解 Rust 中的 lambda 和闭包，因为在 C++ 中，其实相当直白。你知道，如果你深入到细节中，你知道，根据你如何捕获变量，它会消除你 lambda 的平庸可复制性（trivial copyableness）。但总的来说，你有消除你的 Lambda 的平庸可复制性。
But in general, you've got, you know, generic parameters, you capture stuff, you compute stuff, and you're done. Whereas in Rust, you've got like, lowercase fn, uppercase fn, uppercase fn mute, uppercase fn mute once or fn once. And depending on how you like move all your lambdas and closures around it blows up pretty quickly and i didn't know what i was doing when i was trying to compose basically just like closures that were returning closures and capturing different stuff but i asked a chat gpt and it said like oh it's having a problem deducing like the type of this because you're not using enough types uh and until it's used it's not going to be able to infer what you want. So it said the workaround is just like use this macro. It's the equivalent of what you're trying to do, but like it doesn't need to know about the types.
但总的来说，你有泛型参数，你捕获东西，你计算东西，然后就完成了。而在 Rust 中，你有小写的 fn、大写的 Fn、大写的 FnMut、大写的 FnOnce 或 fn once。根据你如何移动你所有的 lambda 和闭包，它会迅速爆炸。当我试图组合基本上只是返回闭包并捕获不同东西的闭包时，我不知道自己在做什么。但我问了 ChatGPT，它说：噢，它在推断这个的类型时遇到了问题，因为你使用的类型不够。在它被使用之前，它无法推断你想要什么。所以它说解决方法就是使用这个宏。这和你想要做的事情等价，但它不需要知道类型。
So it's funny that you were trying to do some functional stuff and then the solution was use macros. And I haven't, like I said, done the, to the same extent of work, but, and also too, part of my problem is that I don't fully understand the ins and outs of all the different, you know, closure. I don't know if they're trait types or what they are. All those fun, fun, fun, fun, fun things. And like putting the dine keyword, I don't understand that comprehensively. I understand the basics, but when I get some error that says, oh, you didn't satisfy this bound on this trait for this thing.
所以这很有趣，你当时试图做一些函数式的事情，而解决方案是使用宏。而且正如我所说，我没有做过同等程度的工作；而且，我的部分问题在于我没有完全理解所有不同的，你知道的，闭包的内幕。我不知道它们是特征类型（trait types）还是别的什么。所有这些好玩、好玩、好玩的东西。还有放上 dyn 关键字，我无法全面理解它。我理解基础知识，但当我得到某个错误说“噢，你没有满足这个东西的这个特征的这个约束”。
I'm like, yeah, okay. Well, I don't know how to fix that. But interesting. So your overall statement is that if you're looking for a functional language, it is a misunderstood impression that you can actually do, like, really functional stuff with Rust. You can do functional-esque stuff, but no more than, like, other imperative languages, really. Yeah, I mean, the way that I think of it is that Rust is a really nice imperative language i'm a big fan of rust um and also rust has some things in it that are often found in functional programming
我就想：好吧，我不知道怎么修。不过很有趣，所以你的总体陈述是，如果你在寻找一门函数式语言，认为你实际上可以用 Rust 做真正函数式的事情，这是一个被误解的印象。你可以做类似函数式的事情，但说实话，并不比其他命令式语言多。是的，我的意思是，我的看法是，Rust 是一门非常棒的命令式语言——我是 Rust 的超级粉丝——而且 Rust 中有一些通常在函数式编程语言中才能找到的东西。
languages like to me i don't think that higher order functions are an inherently like functional paradigm thing they're a thing that sort of naturally occur in functional languages and maybe at a higher uh rate than you would find in imperative languages traditionally, but there's no reason they have to be. You can just have them in any language. What languages don't have higher order functions? Today?
对我来说，我不认为高阶函数是天生属于函数式范式的东西。它们是自然出现在函数式语言中的东西，其频率可能比你在传统命令式语言中发现的要高，但它们没有理由必须这样。你可以在任何语言中拥有它们。哪些语言没有高阶函数？今天？
C? Well, you can pass function pointers. Does that count? I think for C there's definitely an argument that that uh at least it's not not a properly supported um c plus plus i think it's a slightly different story because the c plus plus world increasingly you have function objects um and increasingly that has become the way that we pass um functions and in fact in some cases even the way that we pass functions. And in fact, in some cases, even the way that we define functions.
C？嗯，你可以传递函数指针。这算吗？我认为对于 C 来说，绝对有理由认为它至少不是一个得到妥善支持的……C++ 我觉得情况稍有不同，因为在 C++ 世界里，你越来越多地拥有函数对象（function objects），并且这越来越多地成为我们传递函数的方式，事实上在某些情况下，甚至是我们定义函数的方式。
But I guess C and C++ is an example of a language that didn't have that as built in from the ground up. But can we think of a language that just really doesn't have them? That's hard. Does Zig? I don't know enough about Zig. Zig, I think, is in the same boat
但我想 C 和 C++ 是那种没有从底层将其内置的语言的例子。不过我们能想到一门真正没有它们的语言吗？这很难。Zig 呢？我对 Zig 了解不够。Zig 我认为和 C 在同一条船上，
as C, where if you would count C, then I think you would count Zig, but Zig doesn't have closures. If you consider... Now we're going to get into definitional semantics. Do you want to count a function pointer as higher order? Do you want to count a function pointer as higher order do you want to count a function that is a conceptually if like something more than a
如果你算 C，那我想你也会算 Zig，但 Zig 没有闭包。如果你考虑……现在我们要进入定义语义了。你想把函数指针算作高阶吗？你想把函数指针算作高阶吗？你想把一个在概念上比函数指针多一点但又不捕获东西的函数算作高阶吗？我一直认为高阶函数的精髓在于：我要告诉这个函数一些我想运行的任意逻辑。所以我想，嗯，按这个定义，你也可以说 Ruby 的块（blocks）算作高阶函数，虽然我不会这么认为。所以，是的，我想这是一个在哪里划定界限的问题。哦，等等，所以 Ruby 没有——所以 Ruby 的块是它传递的唯一方式吗？还有另一种传递函数的方式。Ruby 也有你可以传递的 lambda，但是
function pointer but doesn't capture does that count i've always thought of higher order function is really the essence of it being i am going to tell this function about some arbitrary logic that i want to run and so i guess i mean then again by that definition you could say that like ruby's blocks count as higher order functions which i i wouldn't consider that so yeah i guess it's a sort of where do you draw the line question but oh wait so so does ruby not have so is ruby's blocks the only way that it has to pass it's another way to pass like a function ruby also has i mean lambdas that you can pass around but um blocks are a lot more commonly used. I actually never really understood why that was. That's just something I observed in my relatively limited experience doing Ruby code. that a language to for it to have higher order functions that you need to be able to treat a function that you've defined as an object or as a value that you can pass around
块要常用得多。我其实从来没真正理解为什么会这样。这只是我在相对有限的编写 Ruby 代码的经验中观察到的。一门语言要拥有高阶函数，你需要能够把一个你定义的函数当作一个对象或一个你可以传递的值。
i don't think so i mean to me personally i think okay so so i mean taking a step back i may have an unusual view on this but generally my view of the functional programming style like what does it mean to do something in a functional style it just means and nothing else avoid mutation and avoid side effects and to me functional languages are languages where that's the primary way that you're supposed to do things is you're supposed to avoid mutation you're supposed to avoid side effects and if there is support for doing things other than that it's supposed to be a small minority of what you're doing and not i think i think one of the problems is that um the mainstream imperative and multi-paradigm
我不这么认为。嗯，就我个人而言，我觉得——好吧，所以退一步说，我对此可能有不同寻常的看法，但总体上我对函数式编程风格的看法——以函数式风格做事意味着什么？它只意味着一件事，没有别的：避免突变，避免副作用。对我来说，函数式语言就是那些以此为主要做事方式的语言，你应该避免突变，你应该避免副作用。如果有支持做其他事情的机制，那也应该只是你所做事情极小的一部分，而不是——我觉——我认为问题之一在于，
languages like c++ and rust have uh essentially hijacked the meaning of functional. Like, the reason I asked the question about, like, can we think of a language that doesn't have some form of higher order functions is, like, that doesn't really, I don't really think, if we say that all language needs to be a functional language, it doesn't have higher order functions, then, like, what is a functional language? Wait, did, I don't think anybody said that though did they no no but we were talking about like what you know you suggested rust as a functional language connor and i mean i think i think when you're talking in the world like systems languages or in the world of like imperative or multi-paradigm
主流的命令式和多范式语言（如 C++ 和 Rust）基本上“劫持”了“函数式”的含义。我之所以问“我们能否想到一门没有某种形式的高阶函数的语言”这个问题，是因为这其实——我不认为，如果我们说所有的语言都需要是一门函数式语言、且它没有高阶函数，那么，什么是函数式语言？等等，我觉得没人这么说过吧？没有，没有，但我们讨论的是你刚才提到的，Connor，你把 Rust 建议为一门函数式语言。我的意思是，当你谈论系统语言的世界，或者命令式或多范式语言的世界时，当你谈论函数式风格时，这种编程的函数式风格与真正的函数式语言是相关的，但我认为有很大的不同。
languages when you talk about the functional style, that functional style of programming is related to, but I think quite distinct from, an actual functional language. You know, to me, like, one of the key aspects of functional programming is the immutability of values and all the nice properties that you get out of that. And I think that's sort of an essential component. And you look at a lot of what we call functional code
在我看来，函数式编程的关键方面之一是值的不可变性（immutability），以及你从中获得的所有美好的属性。我认为这是必不可少的组成部分。而你看看我们在 C++ 或 Rust 之类的语言中所称的大量“函数式代码”，当然，有很多例子是处理不可变值的，但也有很多例子是你做的事情我们可能称之为函数式风格，但实际上并不是。
in something like C++ or Rust. And sure, there's a lot of examples where you do work with immutable values, but there's also a lot of examples where you're doing something that we might call functional style, but it's not actually that. Well, I think part of the problem
嗯，我认为部分问题在于
is that a lot of folks have different definitions. I think I've even heard you, Richard, at the top of a couple of your talks, like you will state your definition of like, I think you might even have a whole talk dedicated to it, like what you consider a functional people are going to disagree with this because if you take the superset of the list of criteria, whether that's pure functions, higher order functions, referential transparency, you know, first class functions, et cetera, and then, you know, there's 10 or 12 things. Every single person, when they talk about what is the functional programming paradigm, you know, what do you need in order to be functional? Like, you talk to a bunch of different academics and they're going to give you like, you know, 10 different subsets of that superset list. And I'm not sure if you off the top of your head, if you recall your enumeration, maybe we can chat about things that I've heard people say, like are required for functional programming or. Yeah. If you want to give that
很多人的定义不同。我想我甚至听过你，Richard，在你的几次演讲的开头，你会陈述你对……的定义，我想你甚至可能有一整场演讲专门讨论它，关于你认为什么是函数式。人们会对此有分歧，因为如果你采用标准列表的超集——无论是纯函数、高阶函数、引用透明性、一等函数等等，然后呢，有 10 或 12 件事。每个人在谈论什么是函数式编程范式、你需要什么才能成为函数式时，你跟一堆不同的学者交谈，他们会给你列出大体上那份超集列表的 10 个不同的子集。我不确定你是否能凭记忆回想起你的枚举，也许我们可以聊聊我听过人们说的、被认为是函数式编程所需的东西。是的。如果你想给出那个列表，然后在每一项后面加上你同意还是不同意，比如是什么进入了 A 的列表？
list and then like after each one, whether you agree or disagree, like what makes it onto a's list well i mean like i said there's only two on my list which is avoid mutation avoid side effects but um so uh some of the things i have heard in the past so i i'm going to start with the first one that i think is the most ridiculous one that i've heard but i actually did see this it was it was on some link i read it was like hacker news or lobsters or reddit or something but somebody actually said you're not doing functional programming unless you have higher rank types which is the most ludicrous one i've heard because that is just to me is like absolutely zero percent to do with functional programming at all and i don't know what could make somebody say something like that is higher rank the same thing as a higher kind of types no they're they're
嗯，就像我说的，我的列表上只有两个：避免突变，避免副作用。但是，嗯……所以我过去听到的一些事情——所以我打算从我认为我听过的最荒谬的第一条开始，但我确实见过了，它在某个链接上，我读到过，像 Hacker News 或 Lobsters 或 Reddit 之类的，但有人竟然说：“除非你有更高阶的类型（higher-rank types），否则你就是在进行函数式编程。”这是我听过的最荒谬的说法，因为对我来说，这跟函数式编程绝对没有零点几的关系，我不知道是什么能让人说出那样的话。更高阶和高阶类型（higher-kinded types）是一回事吗？不，它们
actually different um so higher rank is like a, for all in Haskell. Like you have to, okay. If you need to say for all to like, it's like, it's about like quantification of, I don't know.
实际上是不同的。嗯，更高阶类型就像是 Haskell 中的 forall。就像你必须……好吧。如果你需要说 forall 来……它就像是关于量化（quantification）的，我不知道。
That's a whole rabbit hole, but at any rate, we'll leave a link in the show notes for folks that want to read the Wikipedia entry. Yeah. Um, uh, but basically,
那是个巨大的兔子洞，但无论如何，我们会在节目笔记中留下链接，供想要阅读维基百科条目的听众参考。是的。嗯，但是基本上，
um, to say that like functional programming programming like you're not doing functional programming unless you have higher rank types is just like one of the most like ridiculous things i've heard in general uh but somebody actually made that claim uh and then defended it when i said this is this doesn't make any sense okay so so that's one um but the more common ones that i hear are like pattern matching people say like oh like this is like a functional thing like pattern matching i'm like i don't think it has anything to do with functional uh another is basically some types so this would be like algebraic data types or uh discriminated unions or tagged unions or like a lot of different languages call it different
嗯，说什么“除非你有更高阶的类型，否则你就是在进行函数式编程”，这总的来说是我听过的最荒谬的事情之一。但确实有人提出了这个主张，当我说这毫无意义时，他还进行了辩护。好吧，所以这是一个；但更常见的我听到的说法是模式匹配。人们说：“噢，这就像是个函数式的东西——模式匹配。”我就想：我觉得这跟函数式没有任何关系。另一个基本上是和类型（sum types），也就是代数数据类型（ algebraic data types）、可辨识联合（discriminated unions）、带标签联合（tagged unions），或者很多不同的语言叫它们不同的
things custom types in elm we call them tag unions and rock enums and in Rust. Basically, you know, you have a list of alternatives and those can have potentially data associated with them. Immutability in general, I've heard people say that like that's a functional thing, which I certainly agree that if you want to avoid mutation and side effects, then yes, immutability is a very helpful thing for avoiding mutation. But I don't think it's an exclusively functional thing. I certainly think any imperative language can have immutability. I don't think it makes a language functional or, you know, a style necessarily functional to have things that are immutable. I think it's more about like how pervasive they are and how, and to what degree you can sort of
名字。在 Elm 中我们叫它们带标签联合，在 Roc 中叫它们……在 Rust 中叫它们枚举（enums）。基本上，你知道，你有一系列可选项，这些可选项可能关联着数据。普遍的不可变性（immutability），我听人说过这也是一个函数式的东西，我当然同意，如果你想避免突变和副作用，那么是的，不可变性是避免突变的一个非常有帮助的东西。但我认为这不是一个排他性的函数式东西。我当然认为任何命令式语言都可以有不可变性。我不认为拥有不可变的东西就会让一门语言变成函数式，或者让一种风格必然变成函数式。我认为这更多关乎它们有多无处不在、以及在多大程度上你可以留在不可变的世界里，还是需要分流去直接进行突变。这些是我脑海中最先浮现的。我的意思是，我还看到有人把那场演讲叫做《函数式编程的精髓》，那是 Functional Conf 的主题演讲，该会议在印度举行，所以我是在远程进行展示的。基本上，我从词法闭包（lexical closures）开始。这些对函数式编程是必要的吗？我通过梳理词法闭包的来源历史，
stay in immutable land or versus like needing to split off into doing mutation directly. Those are the first ones that come to mind. I mean, I've also seen people, so the talk was called The Essence of Functional Programming, and it was a keynote at actually Functional Conf, which is in India, so I was remotely presenting at that one. But basically, I started with lexical closures. Are those necessary for functional programming? And I basically concluded after going through sort of the history of where lexical closures
基本上得出结论：不，这对函数式编程来说不是必要的。但这是我听别人说过的另一个。我举的一个例子是引入 lambda 之前的 Java 和引入 lambda 之后的 Java。这就好比，如果你想在引入 lambda 之前和之后的 Java 中以函数式风格编写代码，有什么区别？最终的答案基本上是便利性，因为从语义上讲，lambda 本质上只是它们以前拥有的东西的语法糖（syntax sugar）。
come from that, no, it's not necessary for functional programming. But that's another one that I've heard people say. And one of the examples that I gave was Java before and after it got lambdas. And it's like, well, if you wanted to write code in a functional style in Java before and after lambdas, like what's the difference? And the end answer ends up being basically convenience because semantically lambdas are essentially syntax sugar
所以不可能是语义上的区别，因为就虚拟机而言，它们是完全一样的东西。那些叫什么来着？是 SAM 类吗？单抽象方法（Single Abstract Method）？有个缩写我记不清了。大概是 SAM 之类的，对，我不记得了。嗯，我为了那场演讲还得去查一下，
for what they had before. So it couldn't be the semantics because it's like the same thing as far as the VM is concerned. What were those called? Were they SAM classes? Single abstraction method? There's some acronym that I can't remember. It have been sam like yeah i don't remember i mean i i had to look it up for the talk
因为我也不记得了。它就像是一个 runnable，我想它可能是接口，大概有一个叫 run 的方法之类的。是的。嗯，你提到的很多东西让我想到了那些实现我脑海中所称的“基于表达式的编程”（expression-based programming）而非“基于语句的编程”（statement-based programming）的东西。所以很有趣，你提到了子类型或仅仅是 ADTs。因为当我思考哪些语言对 ADTs 有极好的支持时，它们与这些紧密相连——大多数都是函数式语言，而有了 ADTs，通常就会带来和类型（sum type），随之而来的是模式匹配，这通常相当不错。思考一下这真的让它变得函数式了，还是说这实际上让你能够编写返回值的基于表达式的程序，而不是像那种我真的很讨厌在 Python 等语言中看到的老派反模式——你在循环外初始化某个变量，然后在循环的每一次迭代中修改它，到头来，你拥有的是某个归约值（reduced value），即总和、积之类的，而实际上你根本不需要所有那些。你不需要看到任何那样的突变。你只想调用一个名为 product 或 fold 的函数，然后把你需要的天生行为传递给它。很多和类型以及模式匹配使你能够做更多那种
because i don't remember either it was like a runnable i think it was the interface maybe um i had like one method called run something like that yeah um a lot of the stuff you mentioned kind of makes me think of things that enable like what I in my head call like expression based programming versus like statement based programming. So it's kind of interesting that you said subtypes or just like ADTs in general, because those are very closely tied when I think about like what are the languages with great support for ADTs most of them are functional languages and then with ADTs typically becomes you know a sum type which comes with pattern matching which is usually quite nice and it's interesting to think like is that actually what makes it functional or is it really that that enables you to write like expression-based you know programs that return values instead of you know you in like the classic
基于表达式的编程。你对这个有什么看法吗？这是我对你刚才所说的话的最初反应，还是说——我的意思是，我老实觉得，和类型和模式匹配本可以同样轻松地首先进入命令式语言，因为实际上它们主要关于条件分支。在我看来，它们主要的妙处在于穷举性检查（exhaustiveness checking）。这就是你可以说：“嘿，你已经涵盖了这里所有的不同可能性。”
anti-pattern that i really don't like seeing in languages like python and stuff is you initial initialize some variable outside a loop and then you modify it for every iteration of the loop and at the end of the day like what you have is some reduced value, which is the sum or the product or something, which really like you don't need any of that. You don't need to see any of that mutation. You just want to call a function called product or, you know, fold and then pass it the custom behavior that you need. And a lot of the sum types and stuff and pattern matching enables you to do more of that kind
我想，我想是穷举性再加上这样一种能力：即只有在设置了特定事物的情况下，我才能访问这些数据片段。所以，举个例子，C 语言的联合（union）就是另一种选择，你当时会想：好吧，
of expression based programming. Do you have thoughts on like that? that's my initial reaction to what you just said or is i mean i honestly think that um some types of pattern matching could have just as easily come to imperative languages first because really i think they're they're mainly about conditionals like what's nice about them in my mind primarily is the exhaustiveness checking that's where you can say like, Hey, you've covered all the different possibilities here.
我有这些不同的形状之一。如果你没有与之关联的标签（tag），那么你就会想：“好吧，我究竟有哪种形状？我必须以某种方式弄清楚这一点。”这是一件极其不安全的事情。所以模式匹配的好处在于你可以说：“好吧，如果在运行时我有这个特定的标签，那么我就能访问这个数据，否则我就不能。”所以它消除了一把枪击中自己脚的风险（foot gun）。这就像是，你知道，它让条件分支更好了，但条件分支绝不是什么函数式的东西。就像每种语言都有条件分支一样。
And I guess, I guess exhaustiveness plus the ability to say, I only have access to these pieces of data if this particular thing is set. So like the, the alternative being like, for example, a C union where you're like, okay,
我想，我想完备性加上这样一种能力，即只有在设置了特定项的情况下，我才能访问这些数据。所以，另一个选择就像是，例如，C 语言中的 union（联合体），你会觉得，好吧，
I have one of these different shapes. And if you don't have a tag associated with that, then you're like okay i have one of these different shapes and if you don't have a tag associated with that then you're like well which shape do i have i have to figure that out somehow and that's a wildly unsafe thing so the nice thing about the pattern matching is you can say well if at runtime i have this particular tag then i have access to this data and otherwise i don't so it sort of removes a foot gun it's like well you know it makes the conditionals nicer but conditions are by no means a functional thing. Like every language has conditionals.
我有几种不同的形态中的一种。如果你没有与之关联的标签，那么你就会想，嗯，我到底是哪种形态呢？我必须想方设法弄清楚这一点，这真是一件极其不安全的事情。所以模式匹配的好处在于你可以说，如果在运行时我有这个特定的标签，那么我就可以访问这个数据，否则就不行。这就好比消除了一种自我伤害的隐患，你知道的，它让条件判断变得更美观，但条件判断绝对不是函数式编程特有的东西。就像每种语言都有条件判断一样。
Every language has some sort of way to do branching or jump tables, whatever it's compiling to. And having some way to associate this data is only available when this particular flag is set at runtime just seems like a kind of a universally nice thing but historically it happened to come out of like the ml family of languages like robin milner's you know ml from 1970 something um and actually i don't know i don't know if that was in the first version maybe it was in standard ml which i think was 75 um but regardless like i think that could have just as easily been something that strausdrup with, you know, in like C with classes or C++. But it happened to, you know, come out of that group. Closures, I think, I think it's pretty hard to do functional programming ergonomically without lexical closures.
每种语言都有某种方式来实现分支或跳转表，无论它编译成什么。有一种方式可以将这些数据关联起来，而这只有在运行时设置了特定标志时才可用，这在历史上看起来就像是一个普遍不错的东西，但它碰巧源于ML系列的语言，比如罗宾·米尔纳（Robin Milner）在20世纪70年代左右的ML。嗯，其实我不知道，我不知道这是否在第一个版本中，也许它在Standard ML中，我想那是75年。嗯，但不管怎样，我认为这本来也很容易成为斯特劳斯特鲁普（Stroustrup）在带类C或C++中会做的事情。但它碰巧，你知道的，诞生于那个群体。闭包，我认为，如果没有词法闭包，要符合人体工程学地进行函数式编程是相当困难的。
I mean, I'm sure it can be done in like if you really put your mind to it but i wouldn't enjoy it i don't think interesting yeah i mean while you were saying that i was thinking like the one of the number one uh i wouldn't call it like anti-patterns but problems that i have with python is like i i tend to write most of my code these days in like a functional style and i make use of the enum class which is python's best attempt at some types but they have no actually did they get matching maybe maybe i need to go look at that they might have gotten pattern matching in like 3 11 or 12 or 13 or something but like i i constantly have like a small function that just takes like a single enum as an argument and then i go if equals if equals if equals and then i exhaust it but then if you use rough or pylint or any one of the linters it'll be like you know
我的意思是，我相信如果真的用心去做是可以做到的，但我不会喜欢它，我觉得不会。有意思，是的，我是说，当你在说的时候，我在想，我用Python时遇到的头号——嗯，我不会称之为反模式，但可以说是问题——那就是，我现在的绝大多数代码都倾向于用函数式风格编写，并且我会使用enum类，这是Python对代数数据类型（sum types）的最努力尝试，但它们没有……其实它们有模式匹配吗？也许我得去看看，他们可能在3.11、12或13之类的版本中加入了模式匹配。但就像我经常有一个小函数，只把一个枚举作为参数，然后我写 if 等于、if 等于、if 等于，接着我穷举了它们，但是如果你使用 ruff、pylint 或任何静态检查工具，它就会提示你，你知道的
function does not have return statement at the end and i'm like well i know that i've exhausted all of them like i don't want to have to put like a return empty string or return none because then it's changing the type or you know changing the semantics of what i want and uh you know if there's a listener out there that knows there is like i don't know i'm not a python pro so maybe there is actually a a nice solution to this but yeah like you don't have that problem at all with with ruster or languages like i assume with rock either right be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adsb the podcast dot com for links to everything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening.
函数末尾没有返回语句。而我想的是，我知道我已经穷举了所有情况，我不想非得写个 return 空字符串或者 return none，因为那样会改变类型，或者说改变了我想要的语义。呃，你知道的，如果听众里有人知道的话——我不是Python专家，所以也许真的有一个很好的解决方案，但，是的，使用Rust或者我假设Rock这样的语言时，你根本不会遇到这个问题。请务必查看你的播客应用中的或访问 adsb the podcast dot com 的本期节目shownotes，获取今天节目中提到的一切内容的链接，以及可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论区链接。谢谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望你喜欢本期节目，祝你有美好的一天。质量低下，数量庞大。这就是我们播客的标语。其实不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。